Hey everyone, it's Dr. Marcon and this is chapter 10 on skeletal muscle tissue.
So what is muscle?
Muscle, it's derived from the Latin word for little mouse.
We know that muscle is the primary tissue in the heart as well as the walls of hollow
organs and we also have skeletal muscle tissue which makes up nearly half the body's mass.
So with the heart we have our cardiac muscle tissue within the walls of hollow organs.
We have smooth muscle tissue.
We have different properties of muscle tissue, we have contractility.
So myofilaments, these are filaments within the muscle, are responsible for shortening
of muscle cells and we have two types of myofilaments, we have actin and myosin.
Excitability, with this property nerve cells excite muscle cells causing electrical impulses
to travel along the sarcolema.
Extensibility, so contraction of a skeletal muscle stretches the opposing muscle.
We also know that smooth muscle is stretched by substances within that hollow organ.
For example, when we have food in our stomach this stretches the smooth muscle in the stomach
as well as urine in the urinary bladder.
The last property we'll talk about is elasticity.
Muscle has the ability to recoil after being stretched.
We talked about the different connective fibers or connective tissue fibers that are
within muscle such as for example elastic tissue allowing for that recoil property.
So just want to go over the terminology that is specific to muscle tissue.
Whenever you see the prefixes myo or myes, this prefix means muscle, sarco.
This is also another prefix pertaining to muscle tissue, sarco is a prefix meaning flesh.
So for example, we have specific organelles for muscle tissue that relate to generalized
organelles of cells.
So with the sarcolema, the sarcolema is the plasma membrane of muscle cells.
Sarcoplasm is the cytoplasm of muscle cells.
We have different functions of muscle tissue.
One of the main functions of course is to produce movement.
Skeletal muscle is attached to skeletal bone and moves the body by moving the bones.
Smooth muscle.
Smooth muscle is important.
We know we find them in the linings of the hollow organs.
Smooth muscle squeezes fluids and other substances like a baby out of the uterus through the hollow
organs.
Smooth muscle tissue is also important because we can find them in the opening and closing
of body passageways.
We have muscles called sphincters.
So these sphincters open and close body passageways.
They basically function as vowels.
They can open to allow passage of a substance and then contract to close the passageway.
Muscle tissue also helps maintain posture and stabilize joints.
This enables the body to remain sitting or standing.
Also muscle tone helps stabilize many synovial joints.
Muscle tissue is also important for heat generation.
So muscle contractions help produce heat and helps with the homeostatic nature of the body
helps maintain normal body temperature.
So in the first unit, we talked about the different types of muscle tissue.
We know there are three types of muscle tissue.
We have skeletal muscle tissue, cardiac muscle tissue, and smooth muscle tissue.
So in this chapter, we're going to talk about these different types of muscle tissue.
We know what they look like under a microscope, but let's talk a little bit about each type
of muscle tissue.
So first, we'll talk about skeletal muscle tissue.
Skeletal muscle tissue is packaged into skeletal muscles and makes up about 40% of our body
weight.
We know that the cells of skeletal muscle tissue are striated, meaning they have those
alternating dark and light bands.
We know that skeletal muscle is innervated by voluntary division of the nervous system,
meaning we do have voluntary control over our skeletal muscle.
The second type of muscle tissue is cardiac muscle tissue.
We know that this is found only in the walls of the heart.
Again, we'll see lovely striations of cardiac muscle tissue, however, unlike skeletal muscle,
the cardiac muscle cells are branching, they're uni-nucleates, and they have structures where
these cells interdigitate, and these are called intercalated discs.
This kind of separates with regards to what they look like.
It kind of differentiates cardiac muscle from skeletal muscle.
Also one of the things that kind of differentiate cardiac muscle from skeletal muscle is that
cardiac muscle contraction is involuntary.
Again, we're not sitting here telling our heart to beat as we sit there.
No, the cardiac muscle actually, there are cardiac centers within our brain.
Also the cells within the heart are under, they have their own ability to contract on
their own.
Then the third type of muscle tissue is smooth muscle tissue.
We know that this is located in the walls of hollow organs just by the name alone.
We know that these cells do not have striations, and again, they are innervated by involuntary
division of the nervous system, meaning they are under involuntary control.
So with skeletal muscle, each muscle is an organ, consists mostly of muscle tissue.
Skeletal muscle also contains connective tissue as well as blood vessels and nerves.
Going over the gross anatomy of a skeletal muscle, it is made up of connective tissue
and fascicles.
We have shes of connective tissue that bind a skeletal muscle and is fibrous together.
So the outermost covering or outermost sheath is known as the epimesium.
Epimesium is dense regular connective tissue surrounding the entire muscle.
The middle layer is the paramecium.
So paramecium surrounds each fascicle, and we know that a fascicle is a group of muscle
fibers.
And surrounding each individual muscle fiber is the innermost layer, which is the endomesium.
Endomesium is a fine sheath of connective tissue, wrapping each muscle cell or muscle
fiber.
So we have muscle fibers or individual muscle cells that come together and form a fascicle.
Now we know that the individual muscle cells surrounded by endomesium.
And then the groups of muscle fibers that form the fascicle is covered by paramecium.
And a bunch of muscle fascicles make up an entire muscle.
And this is surrounded by sheaths of connective tissue known as the epimesium, which is the
outermost layer of connective tissue.
So these connective tissue sheaths that surround the entire muscle or the epimesium is continuous
with tendons.
So when muscle fibers contract, a pull is exerted on all layers of connective tissue.
And this forms a tendon.
Sheaths provide elasticity and also carry blood vessels and nerves.
So here we see a diagram of the gross anatomy of the skeletal muscle along with its connective
tissue layer sheaths.
So we know that an individual muscle fiber or muscle cell is surrounded by endomesium.
That's the innermost lining.
All these individual muscle fibers form a muscle fascicle.
So the fascicle is surrounded by paramecium.
So we see all these muscle fibers forming a fascicle.
This fascicle is surrounded by paramecium.
And then a bunch of fascicles will then form the actual skeletal muscle.
And the covering for the entire muscle is epimesium.
This is the outermost layer.
And we know that epimesium and the connective tissue sheaths are continuous with a tendon.
So each skeletal muscle is, with regards to nerves supply and blood supply, each skeletal
muscle is supplied by branches of one nerve, one artery, and then one or more veins.
Mirrors and vessels will branch repeatedly, and the smallest branches will serve individual
muscle fibers or individual muscle cells.
Now how are these muscles attached?
So with regards to muscle attachments, most skeletal muscles run from one bone to another.
So one bone will move while the other bone remains fixed.
So the less movable attachment, this is known as the muscle's origin.
Okay, so this is the less movable attachment of the skeletal muscle.
The insertion of the skeletal muscle is the more movable attachment.
So the skeletal muscle will insert onto a bone, and this bone is more movable, meaning it moves
more than the origin.
So the origin is the less movable attachment, the insertion of a skeletal muscle is the
more movable attachment.
Here we have an example of the brachialis muscle.
We know that the origin of the brachialis muscle is along the shaft of the humerus.
It will insert into the ulna, the ulna here we see is more medial, it has its attachments
on the coronoid process, which is the proximal portion of the ulna.
So because the humerus is the less movable attachment, this is known as the brachialis's
origin, and the muscle or the muscle tenon will then attach to the proximal portion of
the ulna or the coronoid process of the ulna.
And we know that the ulna is the bone that actually ends up moving the most.
So this is known as the insertion, this is by indirect attachment.
So the brachialis has its origin on the humerus, the shaft of the humerus, and its insertion
on the proximal portion of the ulna, and we know we can move the forearm closer to the
humerus.
So decreasing this angle between the ulna and the radius and the humerus, this is known
as flexion.
So decreasing this angle is flexion, and then increasing the angle between the two structures
is known as extension, like extending your arm.
So with regards to muscle attachments, muscle attached to origins and assertions by connective
tissue, with the fleshy attachments, the connective tissues, fibers are short, indirect attachments,
connective tissue forms, a tendon or aponeurosis.
Bone markings present where tendons meet bones, I'm sorry, bone markings are present where
tendons meet bones.
So again, we talked about the different bony markings that can serve as attachment sites
for either tendons or muscles.
So these include tubercles, trochanters, and crests.
So then we're going to talk about muscle fibers, the microscopic and functional anatomy of
skeletal muscle tissue specifically, the skeletal muscle fiber.
We know that the muscle fiber is also known as the muscle cell.
The skeletal muscle fiber is the basic unit of skeletal muscle.
These fibers are long and cylindrical.
They are huge cells.
Diameter of these cells are anywhere between 10 to 100 micrometers or microns.
The length of these muscle fibers can go from several centimeters to dozens of centimeters.
Each cell is formed by fusion of embryonic cells.
We know that these cells are multi-nucleate, meaning they have many nuclei, and the nuclei
are peripherally located.
So here we see the microscopic anatomy of skeletal muscle fiber, and again, skeletal
muscle fiber is also known as the muscle cell.
So we have individual myofibrils that are basically just long rods within cytoplasm.
So striations of the skeletal muscle are a result of the structure of these myofibrils.
So we have myofibrils that make up the skeletal muscle cell or skeletal muscle fiber.
And again, we have the sheath of connective tissues surrounding individual muscle fibers
known as endo-museum.
So this individual muscle fiber, we have the different organelles that make up this cell.
We have the nuclei.
We have the mitochondria.
Again, there are lots of mitochondria in skeletal muscle fibers because they need more energy.
And then we see the alternating striations of dark bands and light bands, dark bands.
You know, there's the letter A in dark, so it represents an A band.
And the light band has an I in it, so this represents an I band.
And we'll talk about the different bands when we talk about the functional unit of the skeletal
muscle tissue, which is the sarcomere in just a little bit.
So here we see just a diagram of one individual muscle fiber, again made up of myofibrils and
other organelles.
So myofibrils, the striations of the skeletal muscle fiber is due to the internal structure
of myofibrils.
Myofibrils are long rods within the cytoplasm, make up about 80% of the cytoplasm, and are
a specialized contractile organell found in muscle tissue.
And these myofibrils are made up of long rows of repeating segments called sarcomeres.
And the sarcomeres are the functional unit of skeletal muscle tissue.
So a sarcomere, again, being the basic unit of contraction of skeletal muscle, has different
elements to it.
We have what's known as Z disks or the Z line.
These are the boundaries of each sarcomere.
It is then made up of different filaments, we have thin actin filaments that will extend
from the Z disks toward the center of the sarcomere.
And then we have our thick myosin filaments.
These are located in the center of the sarcomere.
And they, the ends overlap, the inner ends overlap with the ends of the thin filaments.
And the thick myosin filaments contain ATPase enzymes, which is important for breaking down
ATP into its components to release energy.
The A bands, which are made up of the dark bands, make up the full length of the thick
myosin filaments, and will also include the inner ends of the thin filaments.
The H zone is the center part of the A band, where no thin filaments occur, so it's made
up just of the thick myosin filaments.
A bands and I bands reflect polarized light differently, so A bands are known as anisotropic
or isi bands are isotropic.
Now the M line, the M line is in the center of that H zone.
So the M line contains tiny rods that will hold thick filaments together.
And then the I band, that light band is the region where with only thin filaments, meaning
there are no thick filaments within this region, and lies within two adjacent sarcomeres.
So if we look at a picture of our sarcomere, we can see that we have the Z disks.
So from Z disks to Z disks makes up one sarcomere, okay, so Z disks to Z disks.
From the Z disk, we have the thin filaments that extend from this line or the Z line,
and then they will extend and then overlap with the dark myosin thick filaments here.
So these darker red lines, those are the thick myosin filaments, and you can see they can
overlap with the center actin filaments.
And the H zone is where only thick filaments occur, and within the H zone you have that
M line that hold the thick filaments together.
So the A band will go from the end of thick myosin filaments to another.
It will contain areas where they overlap with thin filaments, however you reach the middle
part which is the H zone where there are no thin filaments.
And we can actually see this a little bit better in the next slide.
So here we see one sarcomere.
So here's a Z disk, here's the Z disk.
So from Z disk to Z disk, this is one sarcomere, okay.
And then extending from the Z line is a thin filament, this line in blue.
So this is a thin filament.
And we can see at some point that part of the thin filament will overlap with the thick
myosin filament, okay.
And then from the end of one thick filament to another, that makes the A band, which is
the dark band.
So let's actually draw this out, which I love to do.
Okay, so from here to here, that's the A band that is made up of both thick and thin filaments,
which makes it dark.
And then we'll have a part of the A band where there are no thin filaments, so we can see
the thin filament kind of ends here.
So this zone right here, this is known as the H band, or the H region.
So there are no thin filaments here, it's just dark myosin, or thick myosin filaments.
And then in the center of this H band, we have the M line, and this is where the thick
myosin filaments will attach, okay.
So make sure you know the different structures of the sarcomere, what makes up the A band,
what is within the H band, what is the M line, okay.
So make sure to study that.
So there are other structures within the sarcomere.
We have titan, titan is a spring like molecule that will resist over stretching.
Titan molecules will extend from the z-dist to thick filaments to the M line.
Two functions of titan includes the whole of the thick filaments in place, and then unfolds
when the muscle is stretched.
So the sarco-plasmic reticulum is a specialized type of smooth endoplasmic reticulum.
It's just basically the organelle, the same organelle within a generalized cell, but in
muscle cells.
So there are interconnecting tubules that surround each myofibril.
Some tubules will form cross chimes called terminal cisterns.
Cyterns occur in pairs on either side of a T tubule.
So pairs of cisterns plus the T tubule actually makes up a triad.
The sarco-plasmic reticulum contains calcium ions.
Calcium ions are important.
It's an important ion because they are released when muscle is simulated to contract.
Calcium ions will then diffuse through the cytoplasm and help trigger the sliding filament
mechanism, the video in which I asked you guys to watch.
So basically calcium will bind to sites on the thin actin filaments to allow the thick
myosin filaments to bind to the sites on the actin filament and then allow for contraction
by movement of the thin filaments towards the center of the sarcomere.
Now T tubules, these are deep invaginations of the sarcolema.
And the triad again is that T tubule are flanked by two terminal cisterns and this structure
is important because when we have the electrical signal coming from the nervous system for
our muscle to contract, the electrical signal will then travel down the T tubules and then
allow for basically the stimulation to release calcium ions.
And then this will allow for contraction of the muscle.
So here we see the sarcoplasmic reticulum and T tubules in the skeletal muscle fiber.
So this white band right here, this is the T tubule and then surrounded by a pair of cisterns.
Those are the, that makes up the triad.
So once we have again a signal for contraction to occur, this signal will travel down the
T tubules to then go along the tubules of the sarcoplasmic reticulum to allow for the
release of calcium ions and then allowing for contraction to occur.
There are two types, two major types of contraction.
We have concentric contraction.
This is when muscle will shorten to do work and then we have eccentric contraction.
Basically the muscle will generate force as it lengthens.
This muscle acts sort of as a break to help resist gravity.
This is, for example, the down portion of a pushup.
So that is an example of eccentric contraction.
So this brings us to the mechanism of contraction.
We have what's known as the sliding filament mechanism theory, which explains concentric
contraction.
So we have myosin heads, myosin heads contained or located on the thick filaments.
These myosin heads will attach to thin filaments, receptors on the thin filaments at both ends
of a sarcomere.
The myosin heads on the thick filament will then pull the thin filaments towards the center
of the sarcomere.
Now while this is happening, the sarcomere does shorten, however the thin and thick filaments
do not.
They just slide past one another and don't actually shorten, they just move.
So thin and thick filaments do not shorten, but the sarcomere length will.
This is what causes contraction.
So this whole mechanism is initiated by the release of calcium ions from the sarcoplasmic
reticulum.
And of course, this is an action that does require energy, so this mechanism is powered
by ATP.
So here we kind of see a close look at the different filaments that make up the sarcomere.
So we have the thin actin filaments that have receptors for these kind of golf club leg
structures.
These are the myosin heads of the thick myosin filaments.
So once calcium enters the scene with the release of an electrical stimulation from the
nervous system, basically what happens is calcium will help.
Help open the receptor sites for the myosin heads on the thin filaments.
And using ATP, these myosin heads will then kind of pull the thin filament towards the
center of the sarcomere, allowing for the two filaments to slide past one another, causing
a contraction.
So the myosin heads attach to act into the thin filaments, then pivot to pull the thin
filaments inwards or towards the center of the sarcomere.
So the contraction of these filaments or the sarcomere changes the striation pattern.
When fully relaxed, the thin filaments will partially overlap the thick filaments.
And then contraction occurs as the Z disks move closer together.
The sarcomere length shortens, the I band will shorten, and the H zone.
So the H zone where there were no thin filaments will actually disappear.
However, the A band remains the same length.
So the A band being from the end of the thick filament to the other.
So A band remains the same length.
Okay.
So make sure you study this slide and kind of understand what happens to the different
bands during contraction, which one shortens, which one stays the same, that kind of thing.
So here is a picture of a fully relaxed sarcomere of a muscle fiber.
We still have that appreciable H band where there are no thin filaments.
We just have that M line where the thick filaments will attach.
So no thin filaments here, and we see that the Z disks are an appropriate length.
And we can see only a part of the thin filament, thin active filament partially overlaps the
thick filament.
However, when we go to a fully contracted sarcomere, we can see that this H band disappears because
then the active filaments are being pulled towards that M line.
So we no longer have that H band.
We can see that the Z disks are being pulled closer together as well.
However, notice how the A band length never changes.
It still stays the same.
Okay.
And we can see that the thin filament is being pulled towards that center of the sarcomere.
So make sure you understand what occurs during contraction again.
And actually, I've included a link to the video on sliding filament mechanism to help
you understand better that concept.
So make sure you are comfortable with the information on that video.
And if you have any questions, please don't hesitate to ask.
So with regards to muscle extension, the muscle is stretched by a movement opposite that contracts
it.
We have muscle fiber length and force of contraction.
So the greatest force produced is produced when a fiber starts out slightly stretched.
Mice and heads can pull along the entire length of the thin filaments allowing for this contraction.
Again, we talked about Titan.
Just a spring-like molecule in the sarcomeres, which helps resist over stretching, will hold
the thick filaments in place.
Again, we have that A band made up of those thick filaments that do not lengthen or shorten.
Titan will unfold when the muscle is stretched.
So just a table in chapter 10 of your book showing the structure and organizational levels
of skeletal muscle.
So at the highest level, we have the organ.
This is the muscle, again, the entire muscle being surrounded by that connective tissue
sheath called the epimesium.
We then have the muscle fascicle, which is a portion of the muscle.
So within the muscle, we have many numbers of fascicles, and this is surrounded by paramecium.
So we know that a muscle consists of hundreds, two thousands of muscle cells, plus connective
tissue wrappings, the blood vessels and nerve fibers.
The whole entire muscle, again, is covered by epimesium.
The muscle fascicle surrounded by paramecium is a discrete bundle of muscle cells, a segregate
from the rest of the muscle by, again, another connective tissue sheath.
Muscle fascicles are made up of individual muscle fibers or muscle cells.
These muscle fibers are surrounded by endo-museum, and then a muscle fiber is an elongated multinucleate
cell, has striations that we saw in the histo slides.
And then individual muscle cells or muscle fibers are surrounded by endo-museum.
And then within the cell, we have organelles called myofibrils.
So these are complex organelles containing myofilaments, such as our actinar myosin.
Myofibrils are rod-like contractile organelles that occupy most of the muscle cell volume,
composed of the structural units called sarcomeres that are arranged end-to-end, appear banded,
and the bands of adjacent myofibrils are, of course, aligned.
And then within the myofibrils, we have the structural unit, which is the sarcomere, again,
a segment of myofibril, which will go from z-disc to z-disc.
Again, this is the contractile unit composed of the myofilaments, actin and myosin, which
are made up of contractile proteins.
So we have the thick myosin filaments and the thin actin filaments.
So here we see the myofilaments or filaments.
Again, we have the thick filaments held by this end line.
We have the H band here where we have no actin filaments or thin filaments.
And then kind of overlapping, we have the thin actin filaments.
So we have, again, two types of myofilaments, thick and thin, contained bundled depending
on if they're thick or thin.
The thick filaments have bundled myosin, whereas the thin filaments have bundled actin.
And the sliding of the thin filaments past the thick filaments will produce muscle shortening
or muscle contraction.
We also have elastic filaments that are composed of titan molecules that maintain the organization
of the A band and provide for that elastic recoil when muscle contraction ends.
With regards to the innervation of the skeletal muscle, we have motor neurons that will innervate
skeletal muscle tissue.
We have structures within the motor neuron.
So for example, we have a neuromuscular junction.
This is the point where the nerve ending and the muscle fiber will meet.
In the neuromuscular junction, we have structures, which is basically the end of an axon of
a neuron known as terminal buttons.
So terminal butons are located at the ends of axons and store neurotransmitters.
And we'll learn about what neurotransmitters are, but basically neurotransmitters are sort
of like hormones that will help send the chemical signal from the neuron to the muscle.
So between the muscle fiber and the terminal butons at the neuromuscular junction, we have
this space called the synaptic clef.
The synaptic clef is the space between the axon terminal and the sarcolemma of the muscle
fiber.
So here we see the neuromuscular junction and the events that allow for stimulation to allow
for muscle contraction to occur.
So here are the events at the neuromuscular junction.
So first we have a nerve impulse.
This nerve impulse coming from the axon, it will stimulate the release of the neurotransmitter
acetylcholine into the synaptic clef.
So here we see the myelated axon, the motor neuron.
Here we have our terminal butons that contain the neurotransmitter acetylcholine.
So the electrical impulse will travel down the axon, the myelinated axon to the terminal
buton at the neuromuscular junction which will then release the neurotransmitter into
the synaptic clef and from there the neurotransmitter will bind to receptors onto the sarcolemma.
So acetylcholine stimulates changes in the sarcolemma that excite the muscle fiber.
So we have the release of calcium ions before that.
So the stimulus coming from the axon or the neuron is carried down the T2 bills to initiate
fiber contraction with the release of calcium.
So enzymes in the synaptic clef will break down acetylcholine which will then kind of
limit the action to a single muscle twitch.
So you don't want a bunch of acetylcholine hanging out for too long.
You just want one stimulus to occur and then once the stimulus has released a signal into
the muscle fiber that will break down acetylcholine so that we only have a single muscle twitch.
So we can see that the axons of the motor neurons will extend from the spinal cord to
the muscle, there each axon will divide into a number of terminal butons that form neuromuscular
junctions with muscle fibers that are scattered throughout the muscle and we can here see
the that going on in this histo slide we can see branching axon of a motor unit and then
terminal butons at neuromuscular junctions onto the muscle fibers.
So different types of skeletal muscle fibers they are categorized according to two characteristics.
First how they manufacture ATP which is our form of energy that we use to do work and
then how quickly they contract.
So the first type of fibers we're going to talk about are oxidative fibers.
So oxidative fibers actually will produce ATP aerobically.
What does that mean, aerobically means there needs to be the presence of oxygen and then
we have glycolytic fibers, glycolytic fibers will produce ATP anaerobically so anaerobically
meaning without oxygen but we do it they are able to produce ATP through glycolysis.
So glycolysis is basically the breakdown of the stored form of glucose which is glycogen.
So breaking down glycogen will help produce ATP which we use for energy.
So we have oxidative fibers that produce ATP aeromically for these oxygen anaerobically
glycolytic fibers will produce ATP by glycolysis.
So these skeletal muscle fibers will then be divided into three classes.
We have our slow oxidative fibers again oxidative requiring oxygen to produce ATP aeromically
and then example of our slow oxidative fibers are our red slow oxidative fibers.
Then we have fast glycolytic fibers.
An example of this are the white fast glycolytic fibers which we'll talk about and then intermediate
we have our fast oxidative fibers.
So these are intermediate fibers again oxidative requiring oxygen glycolytic do not require
oxygen rather produce ATP through anaerobic means via glycolysis.
So first we'll talk about our slow oxidative fibers these are our red fibers they're red
due to an abundant myoglobin they obtain energy from oxygen or aerobic metabolic reactions
requiring oxygen they contain a large number of mitochondria and they are richly supplied
with capillaries they are slow so it contracts slowly and are resistant to fatigue.
These fibers are very small in diameter.
So many of these fibers again are extremely resistant to fatigue as long as enough oxygen
are as present deliver prolonged contractions these make up many of the fibers in our postural
muscles of the lower back so these are the muscles that help maintain our posture.
And these muscles must contract continuously to keep the spine straight and maintains posture
however because they are thin slow oxidative fibers do not generate much power.
Then we have our fast fast glycolytic fibers fast glycolytic fibers contain little myoglobin
and few mitochondria they're about twice the diameter of slow oxidative fibers however
they contain more myofilaments and generate more power and again depend on anaerobic pathways
so they are able to make ATP through glycolysis or the breakdown of glycogen.
Fast glycolytic fibers contract rapidly and tire quickly they are common in the muscles
of the upper limbs which often can lift heavy objects but for brief periods.
The next type of fiber which are are intermediates these are fast oxidative fibers fast oxidative
fibers have an intermediate diameter they can track quickly like fast glycolytic fibers
but are oxygen dependent they have a high myoglobin content and rich supply of capillaries and
are somewhat fatigue resistant however they are more powerful than slow oxidative fibers
they are abundant in muscles of the lower limbs which have to move the body for long
periods of time.
So for example muscle in the calf of the leg uses its glycolytic fibers to propel the body
in short sprints so if we're talking about sprints, glycolytic fibers are more favorable
whereas with fast oxidative fibers they are more favorable for long distance running and
like we said before compared to slow oxidative fibers we know that slow oxidative fibers are
actually more favorable for the muscles that maintain our posture or standing posture.
So here is a table in your book that compares the different types of muscle in your body
we have skeletal cardiac and smooth muscle it's a great table because it kind of bases
the characteristics based on body location as well as what they look like histologically.
So here we see body location of the three different types of muscles again skeletal muscle will
see attached to bones or some facial muscles to the skin, cardiac muscle will only see
in the walls of the heart and smooth muscle mostly in the walls of hollow organs such
as the stomach, respiratory twos, bladder, blood vessels and uterus.
And here we see a comparison of the different skeletal muscle or a different muscle tissue
under histo slides that we saw in Unit 1 here we see these long parallel muscle fibers with
striations we have peripherally located multinuclei and then cardiac muscle we see the branching
of the cardiac muscle with the intercolated discs as well as striations and smooth muscle
sort of looks like dense regular connected tissue but is different because we have fusiform
type cells within this tissue and it's different from skeletal and cardiac muscle because there
are no striations.
Again I would study the different connective tissue components here it shows you within
the different connective tissue components within the three types of muscle we saw the
different layers in skeletal muscle we can see within cardiac muscle and a museum is
predominant connective tissue that attach to, the endo museum is attached to the fiber
skeleton of the heart so we can see the attachment of these cardiac muscle cells via the end
of museum which will attach to that fiber skeleton.
And then in smooth muscle again we'll see predominantly endo museum kind of bringing
together the smooth muscle cells.
Where we see a comparison of you know whether or not myofibrils are present or presence of
myofibrils composed of sarcomeres yes we'll see that in skeletal and cardiac muscle but
within cardiac the myofibrils are of irregular thickness and you do not see that in smooth
muscle but there are actinomycin filaments that are present throughout smooth muscle.
And then whether or not we have the presence of T-tubules and sites of invagination of
course we'll see it in skeletal muscle we talked about that as well as we can see it
in cardiac muscle we'll see a T-tubule one in each sarcomere at the z-discs however these
are larger diameter than those of skeletal muscle and you will not find T-tubules in
smooth muscle.
And then other characteristics that we can kind of differentiate between the three including
whether or not there's an elaborate sarcoplasmic reticulum using calcium for the calcium pulse
or the source of calcium for the calcium pulse of course we'll find it in the sarcoplasmic
reticulum in all three.
Whether or not we have presence of gap junctions those structures that allow for communications
between cells you won't find it in skeletal muscle but you will find it in cardiac as
well as smooth muscle.
And then whether or not these cells exhibit individual neuromuscular junctions yes in
skeletal muscle and no for both cardiac and smooth.
And then regulation of contraction whether it's voluntary or involuntary.
We know that skeletal muscle tissue is the only muscle tissue that is under voluntary control
versus cardiac and smooth which are both under involuntary control because we know that cardiac
muscle it has its own intrinsic system of regulation.
We'll talk about that when we get to the cardiovascular system with the pacemaker cells.
Also we all have cardiac centers within our brain the autonomic nervous system that will
also control cardiac muscle and again for smooth muscle under involuntary control.
Energy so skeletal muscle utilizes both aerobic and anaerobic metabolism so it can have methods
of obtaining ATP through either in conditions with or without oxygen for cardiac muscle
oxygen of course is required and smooth muscle it's mostly or mainly aerobic meaning oxygen
does have to be present.
For disorders of muscle tissue muscle tissues experience few disorders the heart muscle
of course is the exception there are many cardiovascular pathologies that we can talk
about but we'll wait till the cardiovascular section.
Skeletal muscle is remarkably resistant to infection unless of course you have a patient
has diabetes that's prone to poor blood supply which can cause gangrene and some muscle tissue
if there's an injury that isn't taken care of but for the most part skeletal muscle is
resistant to infection smooth muscle well probably any problems will probably stem from external
irritants.
So we do have some pathologies that we can talk about for example muscular dystrophy.
Muscular dystrophy is a group of inherited muscle destroying diseases the affected muscles
will enlarge with fat and connective tissue which will then encourage muscles to degenerate
or break down and there are different types of muscular dystrophy we have douchens muscular
dystrophy and myotonic dystrophy.
We also have myofacial pain syndrome this is when we have pain that is caused by tightened
bands of muscle fibers then we have a condition that a lot of people that you might have heard
about which is fibromyalgia this is a mysterious chronic pain syndrome that affects mostly women
and some symptoms include fatigue sleep abnormality severe musculoskeletal pain and headache.
Now notice these symptoms are not very specific to anyone disease so it's kind of hard to
diagnose fibromyalgia because all these symptoms could be anything but usually if we have these
symptoms plus severe musculoskeletal pain we can you know maybe rule in fibromyalgia.
So talking about muscle tissues throughout life we know that muscle tissue develops from
myoblast again myo being that prefix that means muscles, blast just an immature type
of cell so myoblast will fuse to form skeletal muscle fibers and then we'll see by week 7
skeletal muscles contract.
So here we see our endodemoric mesoderm cells which will undergo cell division to increase
in number and in large forming our myoblast several myoblast will fuse together to form
a myotube and myotube is an immature multinucleate muscle fiber and we'll have satellite cells
that kind of surround the myotube as the myotube matures it will mature into skeletal
muscle fiber and here we can see a mature skeletal muscle fiber, cardiac muscle usually
by around week 3 we can see the cardiac muscle start to pump blood.
We talked about skeletal cells the last slide, satellite cells surround skeletal muscle fibers
they resemble undifferentiated myoblast they will fuse into existing muscle fibers to help
them grow.
Now of course we'll see differences in amounts of skeletal muscle between males and females.
For female skeletal muscle makes up approximately 36% of body mass and in males it makes up
approximately 42% of body mass and this difference is usually due to the effect of
androgens these are hormones in males.
So males have more androgens that will affect percent body mass of skeletal muscle and of
course with increased age we know that the amount of connective tissue increases in muscles
but the number of muscle fibers decrease you know if you don't use it you lose it.
So we have a loss of muscle mass with aging usually we have a decrease in muscle strength
about 50% by 8 years old and then we have a condition known as sarcopenia, sarcopenia
is just known as muscle wasting.
So that's it for this chapter on skeletal muscle and yeah I'll be prepared for the quiz
you guys.